in the middle of these rising tensions
between the u.s and iran we're lucky to
have someone here
who can talk about all this and other
big issues internet
secretary of state mike pompeo is with
gail he is here at the table thank you
anthony secretary pompeo is here in new
york for a u.n security council meeting
on the middle east you were supposed to
get in last night but even weather
affects the secretary of state yes ma'am
it's good to be with you this morning
gail were you in the ascella in the
quiet car
we made our way here early this morning
we are so glad you're here there's a lot
going on on your plate listen we've got
new tensions in the strait of hormuz
protests in hong kong north korea
testing
short-range missiles but we're going to
start with isis because it's on the
front page of the new york times where
they say
that isis is regaining strength in iraq
and syria what's the reality of that
from where you said so president trump's
been very focused on this we
executed a plan uh with 80 other
countries to defeat isis we were very
successful
earlier this year he said isis was done
and done yeah what we've always said is
the caliphate's been gone and that
there's always risk that there'll be a
resurgent not just from isis there's
risk from al qaeda
other radical islamic terrorist groups
president trump is
very focused on making sure that we
apply the right resources against the
problem set everywhere
to protect the homeland and keep the
american people safe we'll do that
is it gaining strength in your opinion
uh it's um it's complicated uh
there's certainly places where isis is
more powerful today than they were
uh uh three or four years ago uh but the
caliphate is gone and their capacity
to conduct external attacks has been
made
um much more difficult we've taken down
significant risk not all of it
but a significant amount and we're very
pleased with the work that we've done
let's go to uh the strait of hormuz
because top iranian officials as you
know
are getting tough with us saying the
united states to act with wisdom
another iranian official said there
would be grave consequences
if the u.s acts there what's the
situation in the strait of hormuz right
now
because people are concerned mr
secretary that we're about to stumble
into a war
so the good news is we are acting with
wisdom it's wisdom to have withdrawn
from the jcpoa
which was going to put iran on the path
to a nuclear weapon
and president trump is determined not to
let that happen and so we have
conducted our middle east strategy and
our work with iran
to say nope you can't conduct
assassination campaigns in europe you
can't conduct
terror efforts from all across the
middle east you're not going to build
out a nuclear weapons program
we've put in place a set of sanctions
that have denied the iranian regime
wealth
and we can see that that is working
hezbollah has less money
some of the proxy forces have fewer
resources the iranian leadership is
having to make difficult choices about
how to spend
it's now limited money the previous
administration wrote them a big check
sent across the pile of cash and then
opened up the iranian economy so they
could continue to grow their terror
campaign all across the world we'll
never let that
withdrew the deal but we don't have a
new deal in place and people are saying
that the sanctions are actually hurting
the iranian people
what do you say to them the iranian
people know that the
uh terror campaign the revolutionary
campaign that their leaders are
undertaking
isn't in their best interest and i hope
that the iranian people work
to change the behavior of the iranian
regime ultimately they'll have to make
that decision
and we're very hopeful that they will
see a pathway clear such that this
behavior
where iran acts outside the normal
course of what ordinary countries do
uh and they'll get their leadership to
conform to what what's best for the
iranian people
i know you can't give details but can
you say if there are back channel talks
going on right now
yeah i just don't want to talk about it
uh it shouldn't take
reading i don't want details are they
going we shouldn't read anything into
that
i'd say that whether there were or
weren't um we just simply don't talk
about those things in this
administration
can i focus on can we take a look at the
protest in hong kong now in its 11th
straight week
extraordinary pictures coming from hong
kong you know there were violent
protests at the airport and now it's
very peaceful but very big over a
million people in the streets
does does the trump administration
support the protesters in hong kong
president trump captured this i think
perfectly across the weekend when he
said we support democracy we
support liberty we very much want to
make
sure that uh those folks who have the
the desire in their hearts to to protest
to speak out on behalf of their own
freedom their own liberty
can do so they should do so in a
peaceful way and the chinese government
should respect their right
to speak out in the way that they are
speaking i heard him say he did not want
to see a tiananmen square and that
that this could have an effect on the
trade talks in china is it
well look i think i think it's important
to understand that
china needs to fulfill its promises the
the challenge one of the challenges of
the trade deal is you have to make sure
that china actually lives up
to the commitments it would make in hong
kong the chinese government made a
promise it has
a central understanding that there would
be one country two systems
and they need to live up to that promise
on behalf of the people of hong kong
we hope that they'll do that we hope
they'll fulfill their promise not to
militarize the south china sea
this is about china actually living up
to the commitments
that china made north korea you know
when last week
when last we saw the president and kim
jong-un they were standing together in
the demilitarized zone
first time that has happened and we keep
hearing that there's going to be another
summit
what are the talks how are the talks
going on that and do you trust kim
jong-un
so special representative begin who
leads the negotiation effort on behalf
of the united states is actually in the
region
uh today tomorrow i think he was there
yesterday as well
we haven't gotten back to the table as
quickly as we would have hoped but we've
we've been pretty clear all along we
know there'll be bumps along the way
we they're firing short they're testing
short-term missiles they
have fired short-range ballistic
missiles this is true yes i wish that
they would not
yeah but in the end uh chairman kim made
a commitment to president trump in
uh singapore in june of last year where
he said that he was prepared to
denuclearize
the our team's effort of the state
department is to deliver that on behalf
of the american people
uh president trump's focus is exactly
that to keep the american people safe
and if we are successful if we
denuclearize korea
the world and i'll be at the u.n
security council this afternoon these
are u.n security council resolutions
that are putting the boundaries to what
north korea can do these are
global sanctions regime and we hope
chairman kim will come to the table
and get a better outcome it'll be better
for the north korean people it'll be
better for the world
you are the cover story in the new
yorker 21 pages devoted to you called
secretary of trump and it's interesting
because it takes the evolution of you
mike pompeo who grew up in orange county
who i was surprised to
see you like ac dc uh my younger
daughter i did not see that
i still like them today they call you
you've been called an old-fashioned
american your dogs golden retrievers are
named after generals
general sherman and patton are the last
two women in patton
um but the point i'm making is that
people that know you and love you and
support you say look this is a guy who
loves his country
and i think people are surprised to see
the evolution of where you were in the
beginning in 2016 when you supported
marco rubio
and at one point said it's time to turn
the lights down on the circus to the
donald trump campaign
to now being very closely aligned with
donald trump
somebody said you know he actually gets
donald trump what is it that you get
about donald trump that others don't
he cares deeply about america and in the
world that i've worked i worked for him
first as
a director of the central intelligence
agency now as the secretary of state
he wants to see the american people
secure he wants to grow our economy
wants better lives for them
i see that i have had lots of chances to
engage with him you see it now though in
the beginning you said authoritarian
trying to turn the
time to turn the lights out in the
circus i'm curious because
they say about you you are you're very
patriotic you get this question
you get this country you know the
president is not always accused of
telling the truth he's very loose with
his tweets it seems to be opposite of
how you run
your life yeah i i've enjoyed the
privilege of working for president trump
you know the comments from back in 2016
it was a tough political campaign and
when i'm on your team
i am all in as i was and when uh
when my candidate left i was all in for
president trump then as well and i'm in
for america today you have a lot of
support mr secretary they say the state
department morale is better under your
watch
people feel good about what they do but
you've got critics one former
american ambassador who shall not be
named this is delicate describes you
like a heat-seeking missile
for trump's bottom except he used the
other word when you hear stuff like that
to compare how you are with this
president what do you think
i find it language offensive and i find
the statement
ludicrous i work hard i work hard for
the president of the united states who
was
constitutionally elected he is my leader
my task is to share with him the best
information if we disagree
my duty is to go share with him our
disagreements i do that with great
frequency
but when he makes a decision and it's
legal it is my task
to go execute that with all the energy
and power that i have
if he if he wins a second term will you
continue to be secretary of state you
know there are calls for you to run for
senate in kansas
don't expect you to say yes i'm going to
run here gail but if he does
if he wins again do you want to be
secretary of state i would love to serve
for him just as long as i can it's a
it's a great opportunity to get to lead
this organization uh 70 000 plus great
americans who are out there all across
the world
taking real risks for themselves and
their families and delivering good
solid american diplomacy everywhere they
are well you don't have a nickname
he hasn't attacked you on twitter so far
so so far so good yes ma'am
thank you secretary of state for
stepping in it's always good to see you
wonderful to see you too